foreign
everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-3676
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
scp-3676's containment is currently
contested between the foundation and
group of Interest 466. Wilson's Wildlife
Solutions as per the boring agreement
all related correspondence is to be
directed through wws liaison Kim Madison
the designated head of the project
chamber 3676 alpha is to be used to
contain the entity as often as feasible
and monitoring of its extra Universal
passage is Paramount fourth Scranton
equalizers are to be used to negate
scp-3676's effects wherever possible
these containment procedures were
stricken from the document updated
containment procedures as follows
scp-3676 is currently uncontained as and
when it re-manifests mobile task force
Upsilon pioro slings and arrows is to
track and sedate The Entity before
transferring it to containment chamber
3676 beta full specifications for said
chamber are available in the attached
supplementary documentation
description
scp-3676 is an abnormally large specimen
of harpafe hediniana or cyanide
millipate estimated to be at least 1.5
kilometers in length and around 5 meters
in diameter detailed analysis of
scp-3676's biology has not been possible
due to its size and anomalous effects
but preliminary analysis suggests it
functions on an internal body plant
closer to that of most vertebrates than
non-anomalous millipedes it should be
noted that despite this it is a genetic
match with harpafe hediniana an
externally identical accepting the
additional body segments
aside from its exaggerated size
scp-3676's primary anomalous property
occurs whenever it attempts to burrow or
otherwise move quickly between locations
when such an event occurs
scp-3676 will sporadically generate
Class E momentary lapse of Reason
wormholes between Baseline reality and a
related Branch universe and almost
invariably pass through into said
Universe these wormholes are
two-dimensional largely imperceptible
and temporarily stable following
creation existing for between 42 minutes
and 3 months with a mean duration of two
weeks in addition to this their
generation is hypothesized to be
restricted to nx-17 the S photo class
Nexus localized in the town of Boring
Oregon and the surrounding area but this
is unconfirmed as
scp-3676 has yet to leave the area the
effect is purely physical in nature and
SCP
3676 does not possess any additional
temporal metaphysical or probabilistic
effects related to alternate timelines
or casual progression
scp-3676 was initially cataloged on 1206
2015 as part of a joint investigation by
research task force Siegel 9 Oregon
Trailblazers mobile task force beta 4
Castaways and a team of staff from
Wilson's Wildlife Solutions
while successful in identifying the
creature and mitigating immediate damage
to the area disputes arose regarding
which organization should take control
of the anomaly as per the boring
agreement Wilson's Wildlife Solutions
had area priority while Foundation staff
maintained and continued to maintain
that
scp-3676 posed a sufficient threat to
human life to Warrant high-level
containment by the foundation's
department of extra Universal affairs
the following is a record of all major
events relating to
scp-3676's containment
date 1206 2015.
nature of event initial contact
established two Personnel lost in an
unknown Branch Universe after falling
through a tunnel left by
scp-3676 currently deemed missing in
action
follow-up action taken containment
established as Foundation priority on
the grounds that an alternate reality
does not constitute part of the state of
Oregon regardless of its geographical
status containment chamber 3676 Alpha
built with fourth Scranton equalizers to
prevent multi-universal shifts
date 2907 2015.
nature of event it is noted that during
casual discussion that three members of
scp-3676's containment team believed U.S
president William Henry Harrison died of
an infected wound after 43 days in
office rather than pneumonia after 31 as
is established history no other major
discrepancies in Recollections of
historical events were noted
follow-up action taken due to an
inability to ascertain the person's
point of origin and the lack of any
debilitating psychological effects
caused by the incident the decision was
made to assign the staff the positions
of their counterparts under the
assumption that the alternate foundation
will do the same for our original staff
date 0-512 2015.
nature of event power failure results in
a containment breach of
scp-3676 and a number of other anomalous
entities The Entity escapes through an
adjacent Universe in which the chamber
was not constructed Henry manifests 13
kilometers Northeast alongside large
amounts of rubble and several irradiated
Corpses
follow-up action taken Solutions staff
tranquilized the entity at the scene and
begin to Draft plans for long-term
containment Foundation staff object but
wws liaison Madison enacts home ground
priority provided the entity does not
shift universes again long-term sedation
is enacted and remains functional until
2803 2016.
date 2803 2016.
nature of event sedation chemicals are
spontaneously removed from
scp-3676's bloodstream presumably
ejected into a branch Universe of
unknown nature and the entity regains
Consciousness demanifesting almost
immediately mobile task force upsalon
pioro attempt to subdue it upon its
re-manifestation but are repeatedly
dragged by
scp-3676 into alternate universes
alongside near identical copies of
themselves The Entity Escapes in the
ensuing confusion
follow-up action taken the entity
remains uncontained for approximately
six weeks during which time multiple
geological disturbances are noted in and
around the area
date 0204 2016.
nature of event a large statue of
Unknown Origin is uncovered 40
kilometers from the border of boring
presumably manifesting as the result of
scp-3676's activities the object appears
to be a representation of
scp-3676 itself and is inscribed with
the names of several hundred people as
well as what appears to be a cause of
death battle features prominently as do
elsewhere and the greater good
preliminary analysis places its date of
creation at no more than five years
previously
follow-up action taken item taken into
storage further action deemed
unnecessary
date 1105 2016.
nature of event
scp-3676 re-manifests in containment
chamber 3676 Alpha numerous crossbow
bolts are found embedded in the entity's
back and that appears severely weakened
from extensive blood loss
follow-up action taken plans are made to
transport The Entity away from nx17 but
wws liaison Madison objects on the
grounds of preserving natural
parabiodiversity as well as supporting
the group's development of esoteric
containment methods
date 1506 2016.
nature of event
scp-3676d manifests from its chamber
shortly after containment rights are
transferred to Wilson's Wildlife
Solutions attempts to pinpoint its
location and use space fail due to
scp-3676's removal and partial
consumption of the relevant equipment
follow-up action taken
pending see below
following the event on 1506 2016 the
decision was made to contact Wilson's
Wildlife Solutions directly rather than
through a liaison as is protocol Timothy
Wilson founder and leader reacted with
surprise after being informed about the
anomaly and reported that no such entity
existed on their records
when questioned about Miss Kimberly
Madison Wilson responded that there was
no such person on their payroll a Woman
by that name had approached him for a
position some years previously but had
been killed in a car accident shortly
afterwards
containment has since reverted to
Foundation control and the construction
of chamber 3676 beta is ongoing the
location and origin of Person of
Interest 7643 Kimberly Madison alternate
and the wws research team responsible
for initial categorization
are currently unknown
interesting anyway uh I think that about
does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
Timothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
vibing Shockwave
killer Hunter Jew
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
zazapan
Lemke
signor
aletreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
and oh crap guy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos found some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you